this episode is awful, man. Do you think we're not even discussing the algorithm? Connor, you know what? I was just thinking, I was thinking just a minute before you said that, I was thinking I was going to tell you, I think that this is a sign that this is going to be our greatest year of content ever.
这一集太糟糕了，伙计。你觉得我们甚至都没有在讨论算法吗？Connor，你知道吗？我刚才就在想，就在你刚才说那话的前一分钟，我还在想我要告诉你，我觉得这是一个信号，预示着这将是我们有史以来内容最棒的一年。
I think that this is all absolute gold. I think people are going to love this. You think this is gold. I do. Can you start drinking over the holidays, Bryce? Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 164, recorded on January 4th, 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we chat about the algorithm behind credit card number generation. It might be our worst episode
我觉得这绝对是金子般的内容。我觉得大家会喜欢这个的。你觉得这是金子？我是这么觉得的。Bryce，你能在假期期间开始喝酒了吗？欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 164 期，录制于 2024 年 1 月 4 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起聊聊信用卡号码生成背后的算法。这可能是我们最糟糕的一集
ever. I'll let you decide. Two quick announcements off the top of the episode, some good news and some bad news. We'll start with the good news. The good news is I recently discovered a fantastic podcast called Acquired, which has four different episodes on NVIDIA, which is relevant to this podcast because both Bryce and I work for NVIDIA. It's absolutely fantastic. Link will be in the show notes to NVIDIA part one, two, three, and an interview with Jensen Huang, the CEO of NVIDIA. Absolutely fantastic if you ever wanted to know more about the company and why it's so awesome. That's the good news. The bad news is that the audio of this podcast has been heavily compromised thanks to Microsoft. Microsoft screwed us twice. First, my Windows system restarted. We lost all
了。我让你来评判。在节目开始前有两个简短的公告，一个好消息和一个坏消息。我们先从好消息开始。好消息是我最近发现了一个很棒的播客叫《Acquired》，它有四集关于 NVIDIA 的节目，这与本播客相关，因为我和 Bryce 都在 NVIDIA 工作。它绝对精彩。节目说明里会有 NVIDIA 第一、二、三部分以及对 NVIDIA 首席执行官黄仁勋的采访链接。如果你想了解更多关于这家公司以及它为什么如此出色的信息，这绝对精彩。这是好消息。坏消息是由于微软的原因，本播客的音频受到了严重影响。微软坑了我们两次。首先，我的 Windows 系统重启了。我们丢失了
of my recording, all two hours. And second, we have a backup though. We record in Teams the recording of both our audios at once in case this happens. However, Microsoft Teams also crashed. So for the first four minutes, you're just going to be hearing from Bryce. Then we're going to jump to the 17 minute mark where we have my audio from both tracks. Anyways, if you're wondering what happened with this episode, that's what happened. With that good news and bad news out of the way let's get to the episode okay so i gotta i got a problem for you no no we're just gonna jump right into this yeah we are yeah we are okay pretend let's pretend that you are Visa. Pretend that you're Visa. Okay. Well, pretend that you are Visa and I get a new credit card from you. Okay. And you need to provide me with a credit card number, right? It's a 16 digit number. The number of digits don't matter. You've got some space of credit card numbers, some of which are allocated and in use,
我所有的录音，整整两个小时。其次，我们有备份。我们在 Teams 中录制了我们两个人的音频，以防这种情况发生。然而，Microsoft Teams 也崩溃了。所以前四分钟你只能听到 Bryce 的声音。然后我们会跳到第 17 分钟，那里有我们两个轨道的音频。总之，如果你想知道这一集发生了什么，这就是原因。既然好消息和坏消息都说完了，让我们进入正题吧。好吧，我有个问题要问你。不，不，我们直接进入主题吧。是的，我们会的。好吧，假设你是 Visa。假设你是 Visa。好的。好吧，假设你是 Visa，我从你那里办了一张新信用卡。好的。你需要给我一个信用卡号，对吧？这是一个 16 位的数字。位数不重要。你有一些信用卡号码空间，其中一些已经分配并正在使用，
and you need to give me one of those numbers. How do you go about deciding what number to give me? You don't just allocate linearly from the space, one presumes. You don't want there to be a pattern, right? Because if there's a pattern, then people could, you know, figure out, oh, hey, well, I have this credit card number. And then, you know, if I can figure out the pattern, then I can guess, you know, somebody else's credit card number that was issued around the same time as mine. And then I can figure out the expiration date. So you need some way to randomize the number that you're being given. It can't be predictable. But you also need to ensure that the randomized number that your algorithm has picked is not one that's already in the database.
你需要给我其中一个号码。你打算怎么决定给我哪个号码？你不会只是从空间里线性分配，人们会这样推测。你不想让它有规律，对吧？因为如果有规律，那么人们就可以，你知道，推断出，哦，嘿，我有这个信用卡号。然后，你知道，如果我能找出规律，那么我就能猜出，你知道，别人在差不多时间发行的信用卡号。然后我就可以算出过期日期。所以你需要某种方法来随机化你给出的号码。它不能是可预测的。但你也需要确保你的算法选出的随机号码不是数据库中已经存在的号码。
So how do you, what do? What do you do? And one of the reasons I was thinking about this was I was checking out for a transaction online. And there's this thing now called virtual credit card numbers, where for some credit card issuers, you can, if you're going to like, just for even for a single transaction, you can say, hey, I want you to generate me a virtual credit card number that's going to be used for this transaction and then be discarded afterwards. And that got me thinking like, okay, how do they go about doing that? Like just generating that on the fly? And then I was thinking about like, well, what's the actual size of their address space? Do they have enough address space for them to just be able to generate thousands of credit
那么你怎么做？你该怎么办？我想到这一点的原因之一是我在网上结账时。现在有一种东西叫虚拟信用卡号，对于某些信用卡发行商来说，如果你打算，哪怕只是为了单次交易，你可以说，嘿，我想要你为我生成一个虚拟信用卡号，用于这次交易，之后就作废。这让我开始思考，好吧，他们是怎么做到这一点的？就像即时生成那样？然后我还在想，好吧，他们的地址空间到底有多大？他们是否有足够的地址空间来为每个人生成数千个信用卡
card numbers per person. And then that got me thinking about, you know, those little like six digit, like codes that you can send, okay, those ones get reused. And that's probably just like some like rotating hash or something. But like for the virtual credit card numbers, do they have some like fancy system in place where they have a pool of the virtual credit card numbers, and eventually they're able to reclaim some of them? Or like, if I get, if I use a virtual credit card number to buy dog food from Petco, is that credit card number just like dead for the rest of eternity? And so then that got me thinking about like, okay, like, how do you, how do you approach this space? And I don't, my guess is that this is not in any way
号码。然后这让我想到，你知道那些可以发送的六位数字代码，好吧，那些会被重复使用。那可能只是某种循环哈希之类的东西。但对于虚拟信用卡号，他们是否有某种花哨的系统，拥有一个虚拟信用卡号池，最终能够回收其中一些？或者，如果我用一个虚拟信用卡号从 Petco 买狗粮，那个信用卡号是不是就永远作废了？这让我开始思考，好吧，你该如何处理这个空间？我不，我的猜测是这绝不是
a simple problem. It seems simple on the surface, but I think it's not so simple under the hood. so my my question is is if with a virtual credit card are you even able to be refunded when you order something online no clue um i think you can be refunded though yeah i'm pretty sure that that they that that you can get a refund and that's like that's my main thing with credit cards is like one you're protected from fraud because it's not your money. And two, you can get refunded stuff. This virtual thing. But here's the thing with the virtual credit card number. The mechanism by which the virtual credit card stops working is that like after the transaction – like there are some providers where you can manually generate a virtual credit card and you can set, like you can say,
一个简单的问题。表面上看起来很简单，但我认为在底层并不那么简单。所以我的问题是，使用虚拟信用卡时，你在网上订购东西时还能退款吗？不知道，嗯，我觉得你可以退款。是的，我很确定你可以获得退款，这就是我使用信用卡的主要原因，比如第一，你受到欺诈保护，因为那不是你的钱。第二，你可以退款。这个虚拟的东西。但关于虚拟信用卡号，事情是这样的。虚拟信用卡停止工作的机制是，在交易之后——有些提供商你可以手动生成虚拟信用卡，你可以设置，比如你可以说，
I want a virtual credit card number and give it to me with like this expiration date and with this spending limit so that you can't spend more than X amount on that or that it expires after X period. There are also virtual credit card numbers that are generated on the fly. And I'm pretty sure how those ones work is that they're generated, they're used for that transaction, and then they expire like immediately. And the way that the whole mechanism works is it just uses the existing credit card infrastructure. And so if somebody tried to charge something again
我想要一个虚拟信用卡号，并给我一个这样的过期日期和消费限额，这样你就不能在那上面花费超过 X 金额，或者它在 X 时间后过期。还有即时生成的虚拟信用卡号。我很确定它们的工作方式是，它们被生成，用于那次交易，然后立即过期。整个机制的工作方式就是利用现有的信用卡基础设施。所以如果有人试图再次向那个虚拟信用卡号收费，
to that virtual credit card number, it would show as expired or the expiration date would be bad or the CVV code would be bad or it would be over the virtual spending limit that's been set. However, all of the security that's in place, all of the two-factor authentications that are in place for charging a credit card, I don't think any of that exists for refunding to a credit card. If you refund to a credit card and you don't have the correct expiration date or CVV, I don't think that you need that to do the refund. So I'm pretty sure that in the reverse direction, it's fine. Okay, so let's go back to your algorithm question. So you said something about generating a random number, right?
它会显示已过期，或者过期日期不对，或者 CVV 码不对，或者超过了设定的虚拟消费限额。然而，所有现有的安全措施，所有用于信用卡扣款的双重身份验证，我不认为这些对于信用卡退款存在。如果你退款到信用卡，而你没有正确的过期日期或 CVV，我不认为你需要这些来完成退款。所以我很确定在反向操作中，这是没问题的。好吧，让我们回到你的算法问题。所以你刚才说了关于生成随机数的事情，对吧？
Yeah. Okay, but here's the problem with that then like if i just generate a random number at large then um like how do i know that it's not an existing credit card number so surely the algorithm cannot be generate a random number query query the database, see if it's an existing number. And if it is an existing number, then generate another random number. Why not? Well, okay. There's a number of problems with that. One, it could potentially give you a non-deterministic answer. Like, you know, you could end up just taking like a much longer time to generate a credit card number than you might want. And you might gain information
是的。好吧，但问题就在这里，如果我只是随机生成一个大数字，那么，我怎么知道它不是现有的信用卡号呢？所以算法肯定不能是生成一个随机数，查询数据库，看看它是否是现有号码。如果是现有号码，那就再生成一个随机数。为什么不行？好吧，好吧。这有很多问题。第一，它可能会给你一个非确定性的答案。比如，你知道，你最终可能需要比你预想的更长的时间来生成一个信用卡号。而且你可能会从中获得信息，
even from that. Two, that just sounds horribly inefficient to like generate a number and then check in the database whether that number exists or not and then try another one. That just, that seems like that's not, that doesn't seem wise. I can't imagine that's how it works. I mean, you're telling me there can't be like a secure way for like you to click on a number, like give me my next number. It's not like you're going to locally generate the number at the bank and then go, ooh, is this one good? And then it's going to say, no, it's taken by Jack Smith in Oklahoma, USA. Uh, no, you're going to click a button. It's
甚至从那里面。第二，生成一个号码然后去数据库检查该号码是否存在，然后再试另一个，这听起来效率极低。这看起来，这似乎不，这看起来不聪明。我无法想象它是这样工作的。我的意思是，你告诉我不可能有一种安全的方式让你点击一个号码，比如给我下一个号码。这不像是在银行本地生成号码，然后说，噢，这个好吗？然后它会说，不，它被美国俄克拉荷马州的 Jack Smith 占用了。呃，不，你会点击一个按钮。它
going to do that all behind the scenes and, uh, and then give you a number. Uh, second things link will be in the description. We've got a question from Cora.com. Will we run out of 16 digit credit card and debit card numbers, considering that in a lifetime and an individual has a handful at a time, I'm not going to read it out, but literally it mentions that, you know, 10 to the 16 is 10 quadrillion. Uh, and then it says this whole range is not actually in use. Then it goes through a bunch of stuff, check sums, et cetera. And then it says it would take about 800 years before we begin to run out of them. So isn't that a problem? Isn't that a problem? No, because it says halfway through that they start to recycle credit card numbers after
会在后台完成所有这些，然后给你一个号码。呃，第二件事，链接会在说明里。我们有一个来自 Cora.com 的问题。考虑到一个人一生中同时拥有少量信用卡和借记卡，我们会用完 16 位的信用卡和借记卡号码吗？我不会读出来，但它确实提到了，你知道，10 的 16 次方是 1 万万亿。呃，然后它说整个范围实际上并没有被使用。然后它经历了一堆东西，校验和等等。然后它说大约需要 800 年我们才会开始用完它们。所以这不是个问题吗？这不是个问题吗？不，因为它说在中间的时候他们就开始回收信用卡号码了，在
a certain period of time. Oh, okay. They start to recycle the credit card numbers. Which I actually already pointed out when I said, like, my guess is that these virtual credit card companies, they issue it once, and then they just, I don't know what the time is, but they've got this range, and they just cycle through them, and then they probably don't even- Like IP addresses yes exactly um and like cell phone numbers as well like get recycled all the time or recycled all the time and like you get those random calls it's like hey is
一段时间之后。哦，好吧。他们开始回收信用卡号码了。这其实我已经指出了，当我刚才说，我的猜测是这些虚拟信用卡公司，他们发行一次，然后他们只是，我不知道时间是多少，但他们有这个范围，他们只是循环使用它们，然后他们可能甚至不——就像 IP 地址，是的，完全正确。嗯，就像手机号码一样，总是被回收，或者总是被回收，然后你会接到那些奇怪的电话，就像，嘿，这是 Jim 吗？然后你会说，不，抱歉，我刚拿到这个号码，这不是打错了，而是真的就像，哦，我没意识到他们换了电话号码。是的，但我仍然想知道你分发下一个号码时所用的算法。我的意思是，好吧，我们会再问问 Cora。银行是怎么……也许你做的是你有一个数据库或所有可用号码的列表，所有未分配的号码，
this jim and you're like no sorry i just got this number and it's not a wrong number it's literally like oh i didn't realize they switched their phone number yeah but i still want to know the algorithm for how you pick what's the next one that you're going to hand out. I mean, okay, well, we'll ask Cora again. How do banks... Maybe what you do is you have a database or a list of all of the available numbers, all the unallocated ones,
然后你从中随机选择，对吧？这看起来行得通。伙计，Quora 真是一个，我要抱怨一下。Quora 是一个垃圾网站。他们在顶部有那个问题，然后在同一个气泡里，用灰色小字体写着“一个广告”，然后那个链接不是顶部的问题。这是我的算法，这是我的算法，所以这是，这是，这是结构，呃，我们又回到 Visa 了，这是结构，为什么我们要这样做？我们有写好的答案
and then you randomly select from that, right? That seems like that would work. Man, Quora is such a, I'm going to whine for a sec. Quora is such a garbage website. They have the question at the top, and then in the same bubble, in small gray font, an and add and then that link is not the top question here's my algorithm here's my algorithm so so here's here's the the structure of uh again we're back to being visa here's the structure why are we doing this we got the answer written for us
就在这里。不，我，我在这里瞎猜。闭嘴，听听我的智慧。所以你有两个数据库，对吧？一个，我们有一个数据库，存储实际的账户，所有可用的号码，当你分配一个新号码时，你把它从第二个列表中移除，然后当你想要，你知道，生成一个新的，你所做的是生成一个在第二个未分配信用卡列表索引空间内的随机数，然后你只是选一个。你只是拿走其中一个。你知道，呃，确定性的，你不需要做那种在整个信用卡号码索引空间内生成一个随机数，然后检查它是否被使用过，这有意义吗？有意义。好的，但是你说你声称找到了它是如何工作的答案。我现在要指出，这个高质量的播客现在正依赖 Quora 来获取我们的答案。
right here no i i'm i'm spitballing here shut up up and listen to my wisdom. So you got two databases, right? One, we have a database, which stores the actual account all of the available numbers and when you allocate a new number you remove it from that second list and then when you when you want to you know generate a new, what you do is you generate a random number that's within the index space of that second list of unallocated credit cards, and then you just pick one of those. You just take one of those out. you know uh deterministic that you don't have to do this thing of like generate a random number in the entire index space of uh credit card numbers and then check if it's one that's used or not does that make sense it does okay but so you said you claim to have found the answer about how this works i will note now that this high quality podcast is now relying upon quora to get our answers.
等等。我得修一下。有些圣诞灯不亮了。你读给我听，当我在——我知道圣诞节已经过了，而且我是犹太人，但是，你知道，每个人都需要圣诞灯。它说基本上有一种叫 LUN 算法的算法，L-U-H-N，它被用来生成这些号码。酷。让我们查查那个。到目前为止，基本上它说很多这些东西实际上并不是随机生成的。
Hang on. I got to fix. Some of these Christmas lights aren't turning on. You read to me while I – and I know that Christmas is over and that I'm Jewish, but, you know, everybody needs Christmas lights. It says that basically there's an algorithm called the LUN algorithm, L-U-H-N, which is used to generate these numbers. Cool. Let's look that up. So far, and basically it says a lot of this stuff isn't actually generated randomly.
你知道，前一到五位数字被用来识别，你知道，银行、机构等等。然而，这些答案中没有一个解决了生成一个尚未被占用的号码的问题。所以 LUN 算法。等等，我要看看那个 LUN 算法。Teams 的订阅把 LUN 算法解释成了 Luna 算法。
You know, the first one to five digits are used to identify, you know, banks, institutions, and blah, blah, blah. None of these answers, though, address generating one that's already not taken. So the LUN algorithm. Hang on, I'm going to look at that LUN algorithm. The team's subscription interpreted the LUN algorithm as the Luna algorithm.
L-U-H-N？是的。LUN 算法。LUN 信用卡算法是如何避免重复的？等一下。LUN 算法，也称为模 10 或 Mod 10 算法，是一种简单的校验位公式，用于验证各种识别号码。我们开始吧。
L-U-H-N? Yeah. The LUN algorithm. How does the LUN credit card algorithm avoid duplicates? Wait a second. The LUN algorithm, also known as Modulus 10 or Mod 10 algorithm, is a simple check digit formula used to validate a variety of identification numbers. Here we go.
信用卡公司。所以我们在另一个 Quora 答案上。信用卡公司如何避免给不同的客户分配冲突的号码？ChatGPT 的回答，因为显然 Quora 忽略了所有回答的人，他们现在直接去找 AI 了。信用卡公司使用一种独特的编号系统来避免给不同的客户分配冲突的号码。他们遵循国际标准化组织和美国国家标准协会，也就是 ISO 和 ANSI，制定的信用卡编号指南。信用卡的前六位数字被称为银行识别
Credit card companies. So we're on another QuORA answer. How do credit card companies avoid assigning conflicting numbers to different customers? The answer from ChatGPT, because apparently CORA ignores all the people that answered and they just go to the AI now. Credit card companies use a unique numbering system to avoid assigning conflicting numbers to different customers. They follow the guidelines set by the International Organization for Standardization and the American National Standards Institute, that's ISO and ANSI, for credit card numbering. The first six digits of a credit card are known as the bank identification
号码，即 BIN，它标识发行机构。其余数字对每张卡都是唯一的，并且是生成的，所以这意味着实际上只有 10 位，是使用特定算法生成的。这里没说 LUN，但我假设那意味着 LUN。这确保了每张卡都有一个不同的号码，最大限度地减少了冲突的可能性。此外，信用卡公司维护严格的数据库来跟踪和管理信用卡的发行，进一步降低了给不同客户分配冲突号码的可能性。所以 ChatGPT 似乎认为你确实有可能与别人共享一个信用卡号。好吧，等一下
number, the BIN, which identifies the issuing institution. The remaining digits are unique to each card and are generated, so that means it's only actually 10, are generated using a specific algorithm. It doesn't say LUN here, but I assume that means LUN. This ensures that each card has a distinct number, minimizing the chances of conflict. Additionally, credit card companies maintain strict databases to track and manage the issuance of credit cards, further reducing the possibility of assigning conflicting numbers to different customers. So ChatGPT seems to think it's actually possible that you share a credit card number with someone else. Well, hang on a second
因为我现在要共享我的屏幕了。我知道我不应该那样做。是的，我知道。但我们甚至不知道我们是否在播出这个，我们下周肯定会再次录音，我们发布的下一个播客将是 2023 年的。Connor，我现在在做什么？Bryce 正在登录 Insights，也就是 ISO 网站来查找标准。好吧，你知道你提醒了我，嗯，让我们看看，它一定是其中之一，对吧？可能是身份证，身份证。我知道我在这里见过它，对这个问题的回答，是由一个人写的。最后一段说，机构面临 IIN 范围耗尽的问题，因为每个客户发行的卡数量巨大，且用户群在扩大。
because I'm going to share my screen now. I know I'm not supposed to do that. Yeah, I know. But we don't even know if we're airing thising this we're definitely recording again in the next week the next podcast we release is going to be the 2023 connor what am i doing right now price is logging into insights aka the iso website to find the standard well you know you reminded me um let's see it's got to be one of these, right? Probably ID cards, ID card. I know I've seen it in here answer to this question, which was written by a person. And the last paragraph says, institutions face exhaustion of their IIN ranges due to large number of cards issued per customer and an expansion of user base.
许多用户维护多个常规信用卡、多个账户上的借记卡，并且也可以使用一次性，也就是你所说的，虚拟或限制用途的信用卡号码。所以根据这个用户的说法，也许这确实是个问题。另一个说我们还能用 800
Many users maintain multiple regular credit cards, debit cards on multiple accounts and can use one time, AKA what you were saying, virtual or restricted use credit card numbers as well. So according to this user, maybe it is a problem. That other one said we're good for 800
年，但是……标准是 7810 吗？啊，是的。好的，所以那是 7810。所以是的，这是委员会。我很确定这是委员会。Connor，我现在在做什么？哦，有趣，我现在在 Stack Overflow 上。你为什么要……他正把鼠标悬停在加入这个 ISO 的群组上。我的意思是，我想，我想知道事情是怎么运作的。哦，不，他们向我们收费，他们向我们收费三千。我不知道。他们向我们收费 3000 美元。我不认为我能说服 NVIDIA 那是我们资金的好去处。但我想要知道。另一件事是，在 Stack Overflow 上，它提到你实际上不需要检查整个号码来验证唯一性。你可以从检查最后四位数字开始。如果那是唯一的，那么你就可以说没问题。我的意思是，那不是问题的完整解决方案，但呃，嗯，这是一个有效的观点。查询唯一性并不一定意味着去 ping 一下看看这个完整的信用卡号码
years, but... Is the standard 7810? Ah, yes. Okay, so that's 7810. So yes, this is the committee. I'm pretty sure this is the committee. What am I doing right now connor oh interesting i'm on stack overflow now why would you he's hovering he's hovering his
是否真的存在。总之，向我解释一下，我没听懂。我只是，比如如果你只是检查是否有任何信用卡有这最后四位数字，然后你得到了回答，没有。你知道你有一个有效的信用卡，还没有被占用。你不需要查询整个数据库。是的，但很多信用卡有相同的最后四位数字。Ramona 和我有两张独立的信用卡，一张是她的，一张是我的，它们有相同的最后四位数字。是的，我不是说它解决了所有问题。这一集太糟糕了，伙计。
mouse over the join group for this iso i mean i want to i want to know how things work oh no they charge us they charge us three thousand. I don't know. They charge us $3,000. I don't think I can convince NVIDIA that that's a good use of our money. But I want to know. Another thing is that on Stack Overflow, it mentions that you don't actually need to check the whole number to verify uniqueness. You can just start by checking the last four digits. And if that's already unique, then you can say good to go i mean that's that's not a full solution to the problem but uh um it's it's a valid point querying for uniqueness doesn't necessarily mean pinging to see if this whole credit card credit card number
你觉得我们甚至都没有在讨论算法吗？Connor，你知道吗？我刚才就在想。就在你刚才说那话的前一分钟。我还在想我要告诉你。我觉得这是一个信号，预示着这将是我们有史以来内容最棒的一年。我觉得这绝对是金子般的内容。我觉得大家会喜欢这个的。
actually exists anyways explain that to me i didn't understand that i was just so like if you if you just check does any um credit card have these last four digits, and you get back the answer, no. You know that you have a valid credit card that's not been taken. You don't need to necessarily query a database on the whole. Yeah, but a lot of credit cards have the same last four digits. Ramona and I have two separate credit cards, one's hers and one's mine, that have the same last four digits. Yeah, I'm not saying it fixes everything. This episode is awful, man.
你觉得这是金子。我是这么觉得的。Bryce，你假期开始喝酒了吗？好吧。我们刚和 Sean 录完了三集，中间夹着一集和 Zach 的 1 小时 45 分钟的节目，你觉得这内容是金子？我觉得这是金子。这比以前差远了。这是算法吗？
Do you think we're not even discussing the algorithm? Connor, you know what? I was just thinking. I was thinking just a minute before you said that. I was thinking I was going to tell you. I think that this is a sign that this is going to be our greatest year of content ever. I think that this is all absolute gold. I think people are going to love this.
好吧。等等，等等，等等。它在 ISO IC7812-1 里。它是公共领域的。有趣。所以它是最后一位数字。它是一个校验位，是使用 LUN 算法计算出来的。
You think this is gold. I do. Did you start drinking over the holidays, Bryce? Okay. We just finished three episodes with Sean, sandwiched around a one-hour and 45-minute episode with Zach, and you think this content is gold? I think this is gold. This is a massive step down. Is this one algorithm?
我不明白这是怎么运作的。我想我以前在演讲中见过这个。我想它基本上就像你取前 15 位数字，然后对它们执行 LUN 算法来计算第九位数字是多少。不是那个，计算第九位数字是多少。所以，或者不是第九位数字，是最后一位数字是多少。所以这是一种验证方法，可以直接判断这是否是一个有效的信用卡号。所以，我很确定有一个
Okay. Wait, wait, wait. It's in ISO IC7812-1. It's public domain. Interesting. So it's the final digit. It's a check digit, which is calculated using the LUN algorithm.
LeetCode 问题在那里，说，实现 LUN 算法，也就是以下六个步骤。并且，告诉我这个 16 位数字列表中有多少个信用卡号是有效的。等等，它怎么告诉你它是关于……哦，我明白了。对前 15 位执行 LUN 算法，然后检查该算法的结果是否等于第 16 位数字。如果不是，那么你有一张欺诈卡。但这不意味着他们限制了地址空间吗？是的，减少了一个字符，一位数字。好吧。好吧。好吧。好吧。但我们也说过前面有五位数字是用于识别目的的。
I don't understand how this works. I think I've actually seen this in a talk before. I think it's basically like you take the first 15 digits, and then you perform the LUN algorithm on that to calculate what the ninth digit is. Not the that to calculate what the ninth digit is. So like, or not the ninth digit, what the final digit is. So it's a way of verifying right off the bat, like whether this is a valid credit card number. So like, I'm pretty sure there's
是的。我们只剩下大约九位数字了。谁知道呢，伙计？我们只处理十亿个信用卡号码，但是那个算法对我们防止生成一个与别人以有效方式生成的信用卡号不同的唯一信用卡号没有任何帮助，它只是防止你生成一个无效的信用卡号，就像你刚才读的那个答案说，哦，你用 LUN 算法做那个，LUN 算法根本不能帮你生成一个新的唯一信用卡号。那不是它的用途。Quora 更努力点，我的朋友。
a leak code problem out there that says, implement the LUN algorithm, which is the following six steps. And like, tell me how many credit card numbers in this list of 16 digit numbers are valid wait how does it how does it tell you that it's about oh i understand perform the lun algorithm on the first 15 and then check is the result of that algorithm equal to the 16th digit if it's not then you have a you have a fraudulent card. But doesn't that mean that they have limited the address space? Yes, by one character, one digit. Okay. All right. All right. All right. But also we said that there are five digits on the front end that they use for identification purposes.
Quora 更努力点。来吧。我在这一集里有很棒的台词，比如“Quora 更努力点”。而你却不告诉我这是我们有史以来内容最棒的一年。最后。所以实际上，我略过了一些东西，但在更长的解释中，如果这一集真的播出了，会有链接，
Yes. We're down to like nine digits. Who knows, man? We're only dealing with a billion credit card numbers but how but that one algorithm that doesn't do anything to help us prevent to generate a unique credit card number that's unique from somebody else generating a credit card number in a valid way just it just prevents you from generating an invalid credit card number which like the the answer that you read earlier that said that oh you use lun's algorithm for that one's algorithm doesn't help you generate a new unique credit card number at all. That's not what that's for. Quora harder, my friend.
最后一位数字被称为 Lund 校验和。实际上，如果我们倒回到上一段，在所有限制之后，卡的接下来的五位数字与第一位结合形成发行识别码。
Quora harder. Come on. I got great lines in this episode like Quora harder. And you're not going to tell me that this is the start of our greatest year of content ever. The very last. So actually, I skimmed over some stuff, but in the longer explanation, which will be linked if this episode ever airs,
这意味着对于每个主要行业，可以有 10 万个不同的发行商。IIN 的注册机构是美国银行家协会。那么卡号中的最后 10 位数字代表什么？最后一位数字被称为 Lund 校验和，用于快速但不那么准确地确定信用卡号是否有效。所以这只是某种可能商家，比如在每一件事中，我甚至不知道这是否有意义。
is that the very last digit is known as the Lund checksum. Actually, if we rewind to the previous paragraph, after all the restrictions, the next five digits of a card combine with the first to form the issue identification.
你必须 ping 一下数据库，但也许这是你可以在机器上本地完成的事情，可以防止网络请求之类的。这真的很聪明。它是客户端的，如果你这样想，它给你一种客户端的方式来检查错误，或者我猜是愚蠢的欺诈。聪明的欺诈会，你知道，尝试暴力破解那些只有匹配正确生成的一位数字的号码。倒回总结。
That means for every major industry, there can be 100,000 different issuers. The registration authority for IINs is the American Bankers Association. So what do the last 10 digits in the card number represent? The very last digit is known as the Lund checksum and is used to quickly, but not too accurately, determine whether a credit card number is valid. So it's just something that probably merchants, like in each one of the things, I don't even know if it makes sense.
所以它说，你知道，那是最后一位。这意味着最后九位数字，7 到 15，代表持卡人的账号。这意味着每个发行商最多可以发行十亿个账号。所以这就是说对于每个行业，你有 10 万个不同的发行商，也就是银行什么的，可以发行信用卡。然后对于每一个发行商，你有十亿个账号。那些是一些相当大的数字，这是下一件事。这就是导致说我们还能用 800 年的那一个。不，人们生了很多孩子，伙计。
You've got to ping against a database, but maybe it is something that you can do locally on the machine that prevents a network request or something like that. It's really smart. It's client-side it it gives you a client side if you think about it this way it gives you a client side way to um to like check things that are errors or i guess stupid fraud smart smart fraud would you know try to brute force only numbers that match uh you know that that that have a correctly generated one digit. To rewind the summary.
人们生了很多孩子。好吧，这里。我们要继续读，因为我想这里肯定有几个跳跃才能达到 800 年。所以听着，伙计们，这个播客，显然是我们有史以来最好的剧集之一，现在只是 Connor Hoekstra 在读剩下的 Quora 回复，不是来自——作者是谁？Micah Henning。到这个播客结束时，我们将阅读标准。这是来自 Micah Henning，Fiserv 的前安全工程师，我很确定那是那些公司之一。所以那些是一些相当大的数字。为了进一步
And so it says that, you know, that's the last one. So that means the last nine digits, 7 to 15, represent the cardholder's account number. That means each issuer can issue up to a billion account numbers. So that's saying for each industry, you get 100,000 different issuers, a.k.a. banks or whatever, that can issue credit cards. And then for each one of those issuers, you get a billion account numbers. Those are some pretty big numbers is the next thing. And this is the one that results in saying that, like, we're good for 800 years. No, people have a lot of babies, man.
促进卡号的可用性，过期的信用卡号码最终会被回收。而且因为。它说那需要 800 年。老实说，我没跟上，但就是这样。所以，Connor，你有 63 瑞士法郎吗？没有，但我欠瑞士政府的钱比那还多，因为我在我们的旅行中收集的超速罚单，或者不是我们的旅行，是我的旅行。你知道，这很有趣，因为我们在奥地利收到了一张超速罚单。但总之，为什么我需要 63 瑞士法郎，为什么你不告诉我们那些渴望知道的听众？63 瑞士法郎，因为我想购买 ISO IC7812-1 2017 身份证件第 1 部分编号系统。实际上，等等，我忘了这个了。标准，当你购买标准的本地副本时，它们通常更便宜。
People have a lot of babies. All right, here. We're going to keep reading because I figure there's got to be a couple jumps here to get to 800 years. So listen, folks, this podcast, apparently one of our best episodes ever, is now just Connor Hoekstra reading the rest of this Quora response, not from – who's the writer? Micah Henning. By the end of this podcast, we are going to be reading the standard. This is from Micah Henning, former security engineer at Fiserv, which I'm pretty sure is one of those companies. So those are some pretty big numbers. To further
所以让我看看我是否能找到这个的 Insights 版本，然后我们可以买那个或者 ANSI 版本。ANSI，不，不，我想能够买这个东西。好吧，就是这样。好吧。网上商店。61 美元。哦，那是折扣价。它是 77 美元。
facilitate card number availability, expired credit card numbers are eventually recycled. And since. It says that would take 800 years. Honestly, I did not follow that, but there you go. So, Connor, do you have 63 Swiss francs. No, but I owe the Swiss government more than that for the speeding fines that I collected on our, or it wasn't our travels, it was my travels. You know, it's funny because we got a speeding ticket in Austria. but anyways why do i need 63 swiss francs and why don't you tell our listeners who are dying to know 63 swiss francs because i would like to purchase iso ic7812-1 2017 Identification Cards Part 1 Numbering Systems. Actually, wait, I forgot about this. The standards, when you buy the local copies of the standards, they're often cheaper.
是的，但 63 法郎换算成美元大概是 100 左右。或者也许我在想加元。所以我不知道。也许你和瑞士持平。但我知道瑞士很贵。我的意思是，鉴于我们一直在谷歌搜索，63 瑞士法郎换算成美元。是 98 加元。
So let me see if I can find the Insights version of this and then we can buy that or the ANSI version. The ANSI, no, no, I want to be able to buy this thing. Okay, there we go. Okay. Web store. $61. Oh, that's the discounted price. It's $77 for.
为什么？你有什么毛病，谷歌？我说 63 瑞士法郎换算成美元，然后它给了我加元。Connor，如果我买了这套标准，你保证不会把它从这一集中剪掉吗？不，我不保证。实际上，它是 74 美元，所以。Connor，你保证不会把它从这一集中剪掉吗？我甚至不确定这些是否会播出。
Yeah, but 63 francs in US is like probably 100 or something like that. Or maybe I'm thinking of Canadian. So I don't know. Maybe you're on par with Swiss. But I know Switzerland is expensive. I mean, seeing as we've just been Googling the whole time, 63 CHF in USD. It's 98 Canadian dollars.
我觉得这会是很好的内容。哦，那个套餐是什么？套餐可能比那个更贵，包括在内，但是的，我不想要那个套餐。我觉得 Bryce 在假期期间开始喝酒的可能性很大，伙计们，他可能喝了半罐苏打水。是的，好吧。好吧，我们，嗯，我正在买这个标准。亲爱的，我花了 70 美元买了一套解释信用卡号码是如何发行的标准。天哪，是的，如果这最终播出了，我，这真的是很好的内容，我想
Why? What is wrong with you, Google? I said 63 CHF in USD, and then it gave me Canadian. Connor, if I buy this standard, will you promise to not cut it out of the episode? No, I do not promise that. Actually, it's 74 US dollars, so. Connor, will you promise to not cut it out of the episode? I'm not even sure if any of this is airing.
让每个人都知道这一集开始的方式就是这一集开始的方式，我没有剪掉。哦，假期怎么样？新年怎么样？Connor，Connor，Connor，这是最好的部分。你知道我必须用什么来购买吗？我必须用信用卡。所以让我们去这张信用卡，看看它是否给我选项
I think it'll be really good content. Oh, what's the package? The package is probably more expensive than that includes, but yeah, I don't want the package. I think that there's a good chance that Bryce took up drinking over the holidays, folks, and that he's a couple, probably even like half a seltzer deep. Yeah, okay. All right, we're, um, I'm buying the standard. Honey, I'm spending $70 on a standard that explains how credit card numbers are issued oh my god yes if this ends up airing which i this is really good content i'd like i'd like
来使用虚拟卡号。听着，伙计们，我现在有了他的信用卡号，他的 CVV 号。你有吗？你有吗？卡号，听着，伙计们，我现在有了他的信用卡号，他的 CVV。你有吗？你有吗？因为听着，伙计们，我要把这一部分留下来。好的，我会的。你刚才可能听到我把最后 20 分钟加速了 10 倍。我要，已经一个小时了，这一集将在 30 分钟或更短时间内出来，这就是多少。好的，好的，看着，这将在 30 分钟或更短时间内出来。这就是多少。
everyone to know that the way that this episode started was the way that this episode started i didn't cut out oh how, how was the holidays? How was the New Year's? Connor, Connor, Connor, here's the best part. You know what I have to use to purchase? I have to use a credit card. So let's go to this credit card and let's see whether it gives me the option
好的，看着。这将是 Zach 有史以来最喜欢的一集。我们要试试这个。我们要用一张虚拟卡。砰。它刚刚为我们生成了一个卡号。我们刚刚做到了，伙计们。我们执行了算法。
to use a virtual card number. Listen, folks, I've got now his credit card number, his CVV number. You do? You do? card number listen folks i've got now his credit card number his cvv you do you do because listen folks i'm gonna leave this part in okay i will you just probably heard me 10xing the last like 20 minutes i'm gonna it's been an hour um this episode is gonna come out in in 30 minutes or less that's how much okay okay watch this is going to come out in 30 minutes or less. That's how much.
我们不知道算法是什么，但它给了我一个过期日期为 2029 年的卡号，伙计们，2029 年，还有一个 CVV。好的。现在让我们看看我们是否能用这个虚拟信用卡号来购买那套可能向我们解释那个虚拟信用卡号是如何生成的标准。如果你，如果你把它放出来。但是 Connor，我有一件事必须告诉你。你想听吗？它只有 14 页。天哪。它只有 14 页。
Okay, watch this. This is going to be Zach's favorite episode of all time. We're going to try this. We're going to do a virtual card. Boom. It just generated us a card number. We just did it, folks. We executed the algorithm.
那每页多少钱？那大约是每页 5 美元。其中一页是标题，上面什么都没有。它对信用卡号码是如何发行的什么都没说，什么有用的信息都没有。好吧，那真是虎头蛇尾。哦，我们为此付了 70 美元。
We don't know what the algorithm is, but it gave me a card number with an expiration date of 2029, folks, 2029 and a CVV. Okay. Now let's see whether we can use this virtual credit card number to purchase the standard that might explain to us how that virtual credit card number was generated. If you, if you put that out. But Connor, I got something I got to tell you. You want to hear it? It's only 14 pages. Oh my God. It's only 14 pages.
哇，哇，哇。我们没有付 70 美元。如果我们有一个 Patreon 账户，并且我们在筹集资金，那将直接从你自己的口袋里掏出来。你想怎么结束这一集，这可能是录制过的最糟糕的一集？我觉得它是，我真的真心认为这是很棒的内容。
What is that per page? That's like $5 per page. And one of them was the title with nothing on it. It says nothing about nothing, nothing useful about how the credit card numbers are issued. Well, that was anticlimactic. Oh, we paid $70 for that.
我觉得大家会喜欢这个的。总之，你想要这一集的总结。这一集的总结应该是，我相信我们有一些听众更了解信用卡系统是如何工作的。如果有人能给我们指点一下 ANSI，即使我确实注意到有一些大的红色文字说 ANSI 不提供退款，我认为这对播客来说仍然是值得的。好吧，正如承诺的那样，我会不情愿地播出这个版本。请，请让我们知道，伙计们。你可以在 Twitter 或 GitHub 上联系我们。告诉我们。我是对的吗？这是有史以来最糟糕的一集吗？还是 Bryce 是对的？
Whoa, whoa, whoa. We did not pay $70. If we had a Patreon account and we were collecting funds, that would have come directly out of your own pocket. How do you want to wrap up this, what might be the worst episode recorded ever? I think it's, I really honestly think that this is great content.
这个播客是金子吗？我们应该每个月买一次 ANSI 标准或 ISO 标准吗？请务必在你的播客应用程序或 adsbthepodcast.com 上查看节目说明，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的口号。
I think people are going to love this. anyways you wanted a wrap-up for the episode. The wrap-up for the episode should be that I'm sure that we have some listeners who are more knowledgeable about how credit card systems work. And if anybody could point us in the right from ANSI, even though I did notice that there was some big red text that said that ANSI does not issue refunds, I think it was still worth it for the podcast. Well, as promised, I will air some version of this reluctantly. And please, please let us know, folks. You can reach us on Twitter or on GitHub. Tell us. Am I right? Was this the worst episode ever? Or was Bryce right?
这不是口号。我们的口号是带有信息点缀的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
Is this podcast gold? Should we be buying ANSI standards once a month or ISO standards once a month? Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at adsbthepodcast.com for links to any of the things we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast.
这个播客是金子吗？我们应该每个月购买一次ANSI标准还是ISO标准？请务必在您的播客应用程序或adsbthepodcast.com上查看这些节目笔记，以获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论链接，您可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望您喜欢，祝您有愉快的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。
It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那不是标语。我们的标语是充满信息碎片的混乱。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。